hey youtubers is Charlie this going to
be my flash episode 2 video introducing
dr. alchemy a couple other new
characters so I already have a couple
theories just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet so much
stuff to get through so dr. alchemy is
really like the big new intro with Tom
Felton's character he was fantastic I am
so happy they're letting him use his
normal British accent in not trying to
shoehorn in a fake American accent just
because it's an American TV show and as
we saw his name is Julian Albert not
Julian Dorn I think that was very very
particular reason they just they didn't
want you to start connecting dots before
the season had started so number 10 meet
Julian Albert who is a CSI just like
Barry but totally hates them just
because Barry is really shady if you
actually sat down and analyzed his
behavior like you wouldn't have known
his name was edward clariss unless you
did the thing i told you not to do so i
can't trust you so i don't like you I
don't like people that I don't trust the
funny pitch about his character though
is that everybody else on team flash
seems like they totally like him oh yeah
Julian he's great like Barry just has
absolutely no idea what's going on with
him but number 9 dr. alchemy so he seems
really cool he has the Philosopher's
Stone just like he has in the comics I
think we're gonna learn more about that
the next couple of episodes because it
does seem like dr. alchemy is the big
bad at least for now even though we do
have Sava tar he's supposed to be a
separate character so just remains to be
seen where he surfaces but we'll talk
about him in a second a lot of you
probably spotted the name Julian Albert
and like you know your mind just started
going through all the iterations like
Albert Desmond is the name of the first
doctor alchemy he has a split
personality
there's Albert in Alvin Desmond one of
them is dr. alchemy the other is a
totally normal chemist before they did
that though Albert and Alvin were twins
with a psychic link so what might be
happening here because we're dealing
with three different timelines that like
the way Jay Garrick explained it they're
all kind of fracturing so maybe via
philosopher's stone there's like a
psychic link or a connection between dr.
alchemy and Julian Albert so
Julian Albert himself is like a totally
normal person just exactly what he says
he is he's a pretty good CSI that
everybody likes
but without realizing it he is also
connected fundamentally to dr. alchemy
but what happened is is that even though
that was kind of the relationship with
dr. alchemy with the Alvin and Albert
Desmond in the comics to begin with what
they did is they retcon that later and
made it like a split personality thing
so eventually the flash was able to
separate those personalities and Alvin
Desmond liked the good version of dr.
alchemy they actually liked the good
persona was able to lead a normal life
but the thing about the alchemists stone
is that it gives dr. alchemy the power
to transmute elements into different
things like normal alchemy but the power
also works on normal humans so he can
use the Philosopher's Stone to reduce
people to like water vapor or anything
else so dr. alchemy might be leaving
those husks behind that they keep
finding when he gives people their
powers back so to speak so that was
actually I really talked about like two
or three different things there so we'll
skip to like will say like number seven
WTF so the rival is back he gets his
powers so he starts beating the crap out
of the flash with the help of dr.
alchemy but by the end of the episode he
fails and it seems like dr. alchemy is
going to turn him into a husk or like
reabsorb his power into the Speed Force
or it could be a hat tip force avatar
it's just that the arm that grabs him
looks like a gauntlet kind of likes
avatar war in the comics so we could be
seeing the beginnings of sabot our
alchemy says these helping people reach
his potential
you know Barry was like I was just
trying to fix my time line I'm sorry
klaris I wasn't trying to take anything
away from you so they're kind of being
ambiguous with heroes and villains like
it's all a matter of perspective and
then when alchemy says he's preparing
this world it made me think of the four
night crossover like preparing it for
the dominators invasion so alchemy is
one of the other people that knows about
the other timeline but remains to be
seen what he is preparing the world for
but number six WTF just explaining some
of the sabotage stuff that's going on
because they're like mixing and matching
some doctor alchemy sabotage stuff from
the comics
so we've seen dr. alchemy he's the one
who is convincing people to get their
powers back don't you want that life
back it's kind of the reverse lesson
from what Cisco got in therapy like I
feel like these memories of Dante are
just reminders of another life so like
you know Cisco is learning to get past
the fact that there are things that
he'll never get back like he won't get
his brother back
but dr. alchemy is kind of preaching the
opposite of that saying you can get all
this stuff back you can get these powers
back that you used to have but the place
where he is with those followers looks
like the speedforce
cult thats avatar has in the comics it
even looks like the castle where
sabotage main bases so it's almost like
they have a bunch of sabotage set design
with dr. alchemy transplanted in his
plays so I don't think they're combining
the characters but when they started
talking about husks I was like oh this
sounds exactly like this Avatar
storyline because Savitt are gives speed
force powers temporarily to some of his
followers they become like Speed Force
ninjas they go after Barry and team
flash but when they use up their powers
like when the flash family defeats them
they just vaporize into nothingness like
you can hear Bart Allen here just go you
this is gross so that's what I thought
of when they said husk but it seems like
the husks are just what's left over when
the flashpoint timeline version rewrites
the current version of the character so
like you have edward clariss normal
person being rewritten by flashpoint
edward clariss who is the rival with
speed force powers so the regular
version of edward clariss that we met at
the beginning of the episode is kind of
overwritten and becomes the husk so
that's kind of what it seems like is
going on by number five WTF they say
about four people so far have been
turned into husks so that means that
there are 4 new metahumans that we'll
probably meet in the next couple of
episodes but I know a lot of you're like
what about Wally Wally was Kid Flash in
flashpoint does that mean that he'll
also get his Speed Force powers back
since everybody seems like they're
getting their flashpoint powers back I
think it's definitely a hat tip to that
because they wouldn't spend all that
time hyping up Kid Flash only to take it
away after a single episode like it
actually cost them a lot of money to
make those costumes so they're just
gonna like throw that in the garbage
and then never do it again
speaking of getting things back though
number four big one
Connor Hawke is retconned onto the show
because a flashpoint so he goes to
Felicity at the beginning of the episode
dumps all his flashpoint baggage on her
and she's like I wonder if any of that's
going to affect us and she's talking
about like the arrow characters so he
basically checks their database for any
potential changes in everyone's
backstories and finds the Diggle has a
son instead of little baby girl Sara so
they're turning the legends of tomorrow
connor hawke storyline like potential
future into actual future so connor
hawke is now canon to the TV show that's
the biggest twist that the arrow
producers have said is going to happen
because a flashpoint so like no Black
Canary coming back just because of
flashpoint but number three badass fight
between Barry in the rival Cisco with
the save and his vibe gauntlets so
there's actually a whole bunch of Easter
eggs happening here so we get vibe
almost in a costume like he says maybe
in the future I'll be ready for
something like that
so one that's just them saying that
Cisco will eventually wear a vibe
costume but two they were fighting at
the Prescott sawmill as in saw jigsaw
Tobin Bell is the voice of jigsaw is
also voicing dr. alchemy I'd like to
play a game flash so awesome hat tip to
the Saw franchise Barry lays out the
rival with the help of Cisco they throw
him in iron Heights prison number two
WTF he's seemingly killed by dr. alchemy
now this could be dr. alchemy we can't
really tell because of the gauntlet it
could be somebody new likes avatars
avatar war gauntlets in the comics
invoking comic book rules we don't see
him die on screen that means he's still
alive they might save his kill force
avatars appearance in the future likes
avatar just absorbs his Speed Force
because that's what's avatar does in the
comics he steals Speed Force so I just I
feel like a lot of the dr. alchemy stuff
is leading in this avatar stuff but just
remains to be seen how they surface him
on the TV show caitlin snow is hiding
the fact from everyone that she has
killer frost powers so obviously episode
7 Kevin Smith's episode is cold killer
frost that might be where this comes to
a head
but that's a ways off so the team could
find out before that but Kaitlyn's
mother is a character that's going to be
appearing during season three so she has
like a really terrible relationship with
her that could lead to some really awful
accidents something really traumatic
happening with her character just big
episode seven killer frost things
happening but for now it seems like
that's gonna remain a secret number one
WTF though this is kind of fun I mean
there were a lot of like great moments
there were all kind of on the same level
so I don't really consider this to much
better than the other stuff but it was
all really big Jay Garrick speedforce
cockblocks Barry before he can derp
again like going back a third time to
try and fix flashpoint and explains to
him what he's doing to the time-space
continuum each time he tries to change
the past you're breaking it like this
coffee cup I've made the same mistakes
as you so I'm like wait a minute does
that mean the Jay Garrick changed his
own past kind of problems did that
create but he also explains the Harrison
wells you know kind of gave him the
story about Barry's father him being the
doppelganger so John Wesley Shipp the
actor kind of explained that Jay Garrick
isn't going to be quite as nurturing as
Henry Allen was to Barry he'll be a
mentor but it'll be like a tough love
thing like okay you want to be a hero
you want to be the flash put your
big-boy pants on you don't get to take a
mulligan
every time you derp so Jay Garrick just
sounds like he's not going to be hugging
Barry a whole lot this season but just
looking forward to Wally West's getting
his powers back seeing Jesse quick in
the next episode that's gonna be a lot
of fun but let me know like what were
you guys favorite moments from the
episode just seeing dr. Alchemy's seeing
the alchemists stone meeting tom felton
there was so much stuff that's happening
and they're only jamming their foot on
the gas like there's so much new stuff
to introduce in the next episode there
are lot of great character moments I
like the way they change the characters
just a little bit everybody gets to be a
little more complex they get hype it's
going to be an awesome season in
everybody give me your dr. alchemy
theories I still feel like it might be a
dual identity split personality type
thing something that's a slight twist on
dr. Alchemy's origin story in the comics
because there was a dr. alchemy that
worked as a CSI with Barry but there was
also one with a split personality there
were twins I feel like they're doing
something in that vein but there is new
on to the giveaway all you guys have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video so tomorrow new
episode of arrow and then legends of
tomorrow premieres on Thursday just the
society I'll try to get the rest of my
Luke Cage out as fast as possible so a
whole bunch of comic book stuff
happening in the next couple of days
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here to watch the metallo
Supergirl trailer and you can click here
for my Supergirl episode one Easter eggs
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight